[Music]
name's max lombardi and i've been an
agent for 10 goddamn
years you want to know what it's like
let me tell you about it the lombardi
tales
[Music]
don't talk to me about no [ __ ] urban
legends
jesus in our line of work you'd think
you'd know better
what i mean i mean they ain't just
[ __ ] stories [ __ ]
well fine some of them are i mean sure
no gangbanger is gonna shoot you just
because you flashed your headlights
but a lot of them ain't why don't nobody
hear about them
why don't they hear about no [ __ ]
skips we ain't the only ones dancing in
this year party
you know no they ain't full of [ __ ]
look i'll tell you how i know they're
real
okay so this was a while back i was
hunting elves in jersey
what they were short they had pointy
ears and squeaky voices
it's good enough for me were they really
elves
probably not sure as hell didn't beg no
cookies
though i give a [ __ ] what they're really
called no i do not
anyways don't interrupt
so i'm off duty haven't finished up for
the day
i go drinking at a dive in the bad side
of town reminds me of home
right so there's this broad she's cute
so i buy her a drink
one thing leads to another i go back to
her place
no it ain't professional what the [ __ ]
do you care what i do on my [ __ ] off
time
jesus so we have some drinks make some
small talk and i suddenly find myself
crashing harder and buddy holly in the
big bopper
yeah yeah you see where i'm going with
this
thing is the bit where you wake up in
the bathtub with ice
yeah that's [ __ ] they're taking your
[ __ ] kidneys
the [ __ ] do they care if you live you're
just some random [ __ ] who can point them
out in the lineup
it's best if you don't ever turn up
yeah i'm still alive thanks for noticing
you might also notice something they
didn't account for proper like
i'm a big [ __ ] guy 300 pounds
hair under seven foot there's a whole
[ __ ] lot of me
and it takes a lot to take me down and
even more to keep me down i wake up with
this real
bad pain in my side i open my eyes
and there's this [ __ ] with a scalpel
opening me up
i put a stop to that really [ __ ]
quick believe me
that was a bit woozy but i'm a trained
foundation agent
there was a bunch of amateurs it went
down
just about how you'd expect so don't
talk to me about no [ __ ] urban
legends
anyways keep your eyes open this [ __ ]
with a hook's gotta show up sometime
you